what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right so getting into how Jordan
wanted this is one of those Green
Lantern stories that's really really
important and in fact there's there's
actually a couple of those in Geoff
Johns run where they're just really
important Green Lantern stories and
that's why you'll find different reading
orders for Green Lantern in terms of
like essential reading stuff that you
can skip over stuff that you have to
read different things like that but this
story Hal Jordan wanted will be required
and the reason why is because what this
does is it sets the stage for the
introduction of the Sinestro Corps as
well as the star sapphires so again this
is pretty important here it's a pretty
big deal now initially what this does is
it actually gives us a little bit of a
prequel in the sense that this is kind
of a little bit of what happened before
this coming picked up so it's really
kind of between the last three Lantern
story arc and this current you know real
Lantern's story this all just really
kind took place off panel but especially
what had happened is how Jordan
alongside Jillian Pearlman going by the
name cowgirl so we'll just go ahead and
call her cowgirl and Shane Shane Sellars
who goes by the name Rocket Man I had
basically been taken prisoner while they
were on a mission for the Air Force now
the reason why this happened is because
Hal Jordan himself really prides on the
idea of never taking his Green Lantern
ring with him whenever he's flying now
the reason why this is the case is
because one it gives them a sense of
urgency and it allows them to kind of
see the danger of the situation the
reason being because of the fact that in
the instance whenever he's flying a jet
the Green Lantern rain is a crutch more
so than anything else but it's also
Geoff Johns giving to us the reckless
nature of Hal Jordan and that's really
why those two things kind of go hand in
hand with regards to the idea of the
lantern being a crutch it's really one
of those things where if Hal Jordan has
his Lantern ring with him that he knows
that no matter what would happen while
he's flying that jet if it malfunctions
and explodes it he flies in enemy
territory and gets shot down whatever
the case may be it would ultimately lead
to the idea that he will always be okay
because the ring will automatically do
what it needs to do to preserve his life
assuming that he loses consciousness if
he is conscious all he has to do is just
fire up the ring and then he's all set
and he can rescue whoever it is with him
assuming that the you know they're
falling to their deaths or something
along those lines I mean if they pop
parachutes so they're in friendly
territory they'll be fun know but if
they're in enemy territory he can use
his ring rescue them fly them back to
the United States and the day is saved
if he doesn't have his ring that it
means that he has to be on his guard all
the time
now in terms of the reckless nature
that's the other half of this equation
despite the fact that he knows it is
necessary for him to keep his eye out on
everything that's going on to make sure
that he's always paying attention
listening to the people around him what
it also does is it allows him to
basically put his life on the line every
single time he flies and again that's
just the reckless nature of Hal Jordan
but what Geoff Johns run is designed to
do is to provide so much character
development for how and that's why how
we see him with regards to the later
stories especially in light Hal g1 in
the Green Lantern Corps rebirth seems so
different from how we see him here and
how we saw him in secret origin because
he basically grew up he basically moved
away from being just so wildly reckless
he was still a little bit reckless but
it wasn't like I don't care if I live or
die it wasn't one of those philosophies
it was hey look I can be reckless but I
also have to recognize other people's
lives are on the line here and so again
kind of walking that fine line is one of
the things that made his character so
intriguing for a lot of different people
but the reason why this is important is
because of the fact that in his mind had
he been wearing his Green Lantern ring
neither how noir cowgirl or Rocket Man
would have been captured as soon as
their jets were shot down he would have
donned his green lantern uniform he
would have saved them he would have
whisked off and then he probably would
have gone back and you know fought
against whoever it was that shot them
down in the first place the fact that he
wasn't able to makes him feel like a
failure now the other half of this is
that in this moment right now in this
particular instance cowgirl was sent on
yet another mission she was shot down
and she was taken prisoner by terrorists
and so because of this how Jordans more
or less on a mission to find and save
her and it's kind of him basically in
this position where he's trying to fix
his past mistakes now another aspect of
this is that cowgirl and Hal Jordan do
share somewhat of romance the difference
here is that the romance they share is
nothing like what he had with Carol
Ferris with Carol Ferris it was a lot
more intimate it was a lot more personal
it was really the possibility that they
could have shared a life together now
that's the old school back in the day
Carol Ferris and Hal Jordan really one
of the things that Geoff Johns kind of
worked on with the idea of the
characters was to essentially create
this romantic tension will they won't
they that kind of thing you know now of
course it really was a scenario where
Carol Ferris essentially said look you
know I run a business you work for me
that's where the relationship stops but
the question was always asked by fans
are they going to get together is Carol
Ferris going to be the Lois Lane
of how Jordans life is she's going to be
the damsel in distress the one he always
saves the ones he would go to the ends
of the earth to make sure that she
stayed protected and so that seems to be
the implication here to Hal and Carol
that maybe they'll go along that
direction now of course you know we know
there's some struggle and strikes in
between but the fact remains here that
with regards to how Jordan trying to
track down these terrorists ultimately
he's met with a global Guardians now
keep in mind this is all post Infinite
Crisis and the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that DC use
Infinite Crisis as a way to reinvigorate
and relaunch different characters and
teams it was much like when Marvel had
their Avengers disassembled then they
launched House of them then they gave us
new Avengers with regards to DC's
Infinite Crisis we had the global
Guardians then we had Infinite Crisis
and then we had the global Guardians
relaunched and revamped as an entirely
new team designed for the purpose of
giving us a new roster new individuals
so on and so forth now under normal
circumstances the global guardians are
superheroes but the way they're
conducting themselves here are as
villains and they were really kind of
like a background theme with regards to
Hal Jordan and the green lantern we
didn't really you know we wouldnt really
do a whole lot of discussion within just
because you know you'd have like a
single panel or a single page and it
would have taken away from the overall
flow of the discussion that we were
having at the time but effectively every
single time they made an appearance and
Geoff Johns Green Lantern so far the Hal
Jordan stories ultimately it seemed like
they were reporting to somebody else or
working for somebody else and they were
looking to track down Hal Jordan and to
basically take him prisoner and so what
seems to be taking place here is that
someone somewhere has put a bounty on
the head of Hal Jordan and what we end
up finding out is that the person that's
done this is a guy by the name of Ayman
sword the son of Adam soar now the
reason why this is important is because
of the fact that this is Geoff Johns
harkening all the way back to the secret
origin of Hal Jordan when he first
gained his Lantern rank and the idea was
that when that happened Aven soar had
basically crash-landed on earth and he
had told his ring go find somebody
worthy of becoming a Green Lantern now
this is where Geoff Johns kind of plays
it fast and loose in terms of how the
Green Lantern rings function which is
kind of ironic because he's pretty
tedious in terms of the nature of the
Lantern rings who can wield what rings
what determines their worthiness or
their ability to wield it not kind of
thing but on the whole the idea seems to
be that whenever a Green Lantern died
the ring will basically say you know
Green Lantern of sector whatever
deceased seeking out a new Green Lantern
seeking out a new host it seems as
though the rings will basically seek out
the most worthy person in the immediate
vicinity and then just race them back to
OA just because it makes the most sense
right I mean if a Green Lantern dies the
immediate job is to keep that number
going one Green Lantern dies one takes
the place the integrity of the Green
Lantern course and number is maintained
so it will always be 5200 or 5400 I came
over how many there are right now but
the fact remains that that number will
always be maintained the issue here is
that Amon soar basically takes the stand
that as the as the son of abon soar
he should have been the one to receive
his father's ring but the indication
here is that it doesn't work that way
the Lantern rings don't automatically
pass down based on genealogy you know
the son is not guaranteed to get his
father's rank there's times where that
happened that's true but for whatever
reason the ring immediately sought on
Hal Jordan instead of Ayman sword and
this really seem to make the sense
because of the fact that a mister was on
the other side of the universe and so it
was just kind of a circumstance it sort
of worked itself out that way now the
reason why I say this story is so
important is because what we do is we
transition to a place called Salisbury
England and there is basically some girl
that's getting knocked on by some guy
and in this guy's you know trying to in
trying to make some moves when she comes
across a glowing purple pink Jim now of
course this Jim communicates directly
with her and says here's the real
motivations of the sky
this guy doesn't really care about you
this guy's not really interested in you
this guy is only after one thing now of
course when the girl picks up this Jim
it bonds with her and she becomes a star
sapphire now of course again this is
really kind of a cool scenario because
all of this is leading up to the
formation of the star sapphires you know
so their evolution as a team that's one
of the reasons why I wanted to bring
that up and so what we end up doing is
we actually end up coming back to Hal
Jordan again and so ultimately we end up
finding out that there are a group of
individuals I believe they're called the
faceless hunters um but they were
basically telepathically controlling the
global Guardians and that's the reason
why the global Guardians were working
directly against their normal role of
superheroes and trying to track down Hal
Jordan because of the fact that Eamonn
saw had put this bounty out on Hal
Jordans head really these these faceless
guys were one of the many people who
responded and we're using the global
guardians as a way to track down how now
this made sense if you are a man just
because of the fact that it's really
just a way to keep yourself away from
being ill intervener being mixed into
the whole fray you know it's one of
those things where if you're going to
issue a bounty you don't do it yourself
you issue a bat let you send out a
bounty you hire a guy who hires a guy
who hires a guy that initiates the
bounty that way there's so many lines of
buffering or so much confusion and
conflicts in there no one can ever
feasibly trace it back to you not only
that in the midst of all this conflict
and in the midst of all this chaos and
so on we actually end up joining up with
Alan Scott and as well as the rest of
the Justice League when they arrived on
the scene now Alan Scott presents kind
of a funny scenario and the reason why
is because of the fact that he's a Green
Lantern but not a Green Lantern at the
same time and this is actually very
important when it comes to the character
of Kyle Rayner and we'll have that
discussion once we get to like you know
ion and the torch bearer and that kind
of thing but the fact remains that on
Scott is basically empowered by mystical
energies from another universe from
earth to again it gets kind of crazy and
so I think that's the discussion this
best isolated to context because really
it's kind of the power of Alan Scott it
was sort of pushed in to Kyle Rayner
that makes him so unique he has the
power of the Green Lantern's and the
power of the star heart but again it's
really more kind of like a car waiting
thing but you know Alan Scott again I
think people kind of find them confusing
because one of the big questions they
have is we've got the traditional Green
Lantern's of Jon Stewart and you know
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan and Kilowog
all that kind of stuff and then we have
Alan Scott just kind of out there in
left field
how does he reside what's the basis
behind his power so we might be like an
origin video or something along those
lines where it kind of explains the
basis behind his powers and what he's
capable of if for no other reason than
to kind of you know shine a little light
on the whole concept of his character
but the fact remains here that wood held
orden more or less making his escape you
know kind of tracking down who it was
the initiated all you know all these
bounties and the Justice League
essentially dealing with the fallout we
end up joining him was he's captured by
a masseur and what we end up finding out
is that again a masseur really did all
of this just for the purpose of getting
ahold of what he believed to be his
father's ring of stepping into the
rightful heir of the next Green Lantern
following the death of his father
essentially taking Hal Jordans place but
in the middle of all this we actually
kind of jumped back to the Justice
League for a second and we actually end
up joining with Batman in Gotham City
finding
you know some of his own foes and then
out of the middle of nowhere suddenly
it's Bruce Wayne of the planet Earth you
have the ability to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps there was
a moment where Batman was part of the
Sinestro Corps and it's so cool because
they basically say you've been chosen to
represent space sector 281 for the issue
with this is that Batman's willpower is
so extreme that he actually overrides
the Yellow Lantern ring he overrides his
ability to take possession of him and so
because of that the Yellow Lantern ring
basically says look you've got too much
willpower you're better suited as a
Green Lantern than a yellow lantern and
essentially just kind of bails out and
goes and searches for more suitable
hosts now the ring kind of says that it
rejects him and true that's really more
like that and rejecting the ring but
this is one of the cool things you know
now the reason why this also happened is
remember we had covered this in one of
our previous videos Batman used the
Green Lantern ring by Hal Jordan it was
only for a moment Hal Jordan gave it to
Batman so that man could make constructs
of his parents and help to kind of move
past all his regret and all his remorse
over his parents deaths but the fact
that he was able to use a Green Lantern
ring means he's best suited for a Green
Lantern ring as opposed to a Sinestro
Corps ring so if the Sinestro Corps ring
really kind of looks at him it's painted
really kind of looks at him as hey look
you've got Green Lantern energy on you
and then the force goes and searches off
a new host but the funny thing about
this is it when it happens Batman's
response was like what the hell was that
it was really kind of funny it's just
like this quick thing because it
happened so fast I mean honestly it
probably takes it probably takes place
over the span of like like five seconds
right like the ring pops up Bruce Wayne
you have the power to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps you'll be
subjected to training he's like what the
hell and there's like get off of me and
like the Rings like up air and then it
takes off and it just it happened so
fast he's just like what in the hell
this is really funny to see that happen
but in the midst of this whole uh this
whole attempt by Amos or to basically
you know kill Hal Jordan to essentially
take over the role of his father
ultimately the ring that rejected Batman
binds itself to a man sort sensibly says
you've been inducted into the Sinestro
Corps you have the power to instill
great fear that kind of thing now again
this is Geoff Johns bringing in the idea
of the Sinestro Corps and that's how it
works that's all Geoff Johns does this
and that's why it's so cool initially it
starts out as a trick
a character somewhere on another planet
is suddenly inducted into the Sinestro
Corps and that's it that's the only
thing you get you just get like one
panel where it's like you have the
ability to instill great fear welcome to
the Sinestro Corps and here's like what
and then you don't hear hide nor hair of
the Sinestro Corps for three or four
volumes of books for like seven story
arcs you don't hear anything and then
suddenly a masseur shows up on earth
tries to kill Hal Jordan and he's
brought into the Sinestro Corps
that's why geoff johns writing works so
well because we get this great big huge
grandiose Sinestro Corps war storyline
with a green LED or I guess the
guardians of the universe has to totally
restructure how the Green Lantern rings
work why because over the course these
little tidbits here and there this story
here that story there that story over
there the Sinestro Corps we're slowly
introduced but the longer the stories go
on the more people get brought in the
bigger the whole revelation of the
Sinestro Corps becomes so instead of
just one person gets inducted in the
Sinestro Corps and a single comics only
it's three people are brought into the
Sinestro Corps and then seven people are
brought into the Sinestro Corps and the
numbers just keep getting bigger and
bigger and so it's literally an incoming
book build up to this insanely good
story because I leave you guys read
Sinestro Corps war it is amazing it is
such a good story minutes absolutely
chase I mean if God was right in Green
Lantern that's exactly what it would
look like Sinestro Corps award it is an
amazing story so what we end up doing
here is we pick up with the tail end of
this conversation or I guess a tail into
this video and of course we're Hal
Jordan kind of goes to pay his respects
to advence or realizing that a band
hadn't had a son because again this is
the first time that he knew that a band
saw her had a son of course he really
kind of modifies his gravestone to say
you know he was he was also a father you
know paying respects to the family to
the legacy that a Ventura had created
and that sort of thing but we also pick
up in Northern California just outside
fares air and what we end up having is
this woman the first star sapphire that
we saw here crash lands and the idea is
that the Star Sapphire is jumping from
host to host finding a way to reconnect
itself with Hal Jordan once again but
when that being said guys if you are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core we have an oath now we
have a ring now we have rules and
limitations on stuff then our
can and can't do make sure you guys
check out my Twitter I am going to pin
that to the front so as soon as you go
to my Twitter at comments explained
you'll immediately see that stuff there
you'll see what we can do what we can do
what our rings are about all that kind
of get stuff what our rings look like
because they look really really cool and
yeah so I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]
you